one of the co-producers on this album is
sir paul mccartney on the song by
valentine what was it like being in
studio with him you know what's funny is
that everyone said how did you get him
but
i didn't get him he called us his his
manager scott called yeah and said we
know you're making a record and paul
thinks that you would do this song
really great what if it rained
we didn't care
i got the uk number and i said hello and
this man said oh it's it's paul mack he
said
and i said hey it's mike boobs
no you didn't you didn't that's exactly
what i said and he was so sweet my
valentines
who had the best reaction to you saying
that you were going to be doing this
with paul mccartney me i had the best
reaction yeah because on that same phone
call
when he said he would do it
i
i
i didn't know what to do so i just i
just started to punch my fist in there
and i was quiet about it and then he
thought he lost me he said hello hello
are you still there and i said yes he
said oh i thought i lost you i said no i
was just pooping my pants my
valentine
you have so many celebrity friends and
connections your publicist also works
with madonna and cher would you duet
with them together like the three of you
i was very close to working with cher
just a little while ago there was a
christmas thing or something i was doing
unfortunately that didn't happen but
michael's new album higher out march
25th is full of new hits like i'll never
not love you
[Music]
the lead single is called i'll never
stop loving you which i can only imagine
is about your beautiful wife lou
um what was her reaction to the song
when she first heard it
thank you for saying that personally
there's two i'm gonna correct two little
tiny corrections number one is the song
is called i'll never not love you that's
okay
and number two i didn't for my wife
i wrote it actually for chick-fil-a
[Music]